the year 2002 the problem farmers in
Afghanistan are growing poppies for the
illegal drug market and after all we've
done for them the solution cash for
puppies a $30 million program to pay
Farmers $700 an acre to destroy their
crops sounds like a great idea with the
best of intentions what could possibly
go wrong turns out you can't get paid to
destroy your poppy crop if you don't
have a poppy crop poppy cultivation
exploded with many thoughtful Afghans
making sure to Harvest and sell the
valuable sap on the black market before
destroying the remaining plants to
comply with the program getting paid
twice for the same crop the project was
such a fiasco that one British
agricultural expert called it an
appalling piece of complete raw naiv put
that in your pipe and smoke it